Duke and Duchess of Sussex will no  longer be working members of the royal  family that means they'll no longer be  given the title of their Royal Highness  and won't be funded by the public well  this is the statement from Her Majesty  the Queen it says following many months  of conversations and more recent  discussions I'm pleased that together we  found a constructive and supportive way  forward for my grandson and his family  Harry Megan and Archie will always be  much-loved members of my family I  recognised the challenges that they've  experienced as a result of intense  scrutiny over the last two years and  support their wish for a more  independent life I want to thank them  for all their dedicated work across this  country the Commonwealth and beyond and  I'm particularly proud of how Megan has  so quickly become one of the family she  goes on to say it is my whole family's  hope that today's agreement allows them  to start building a happy and peaceful  new life  you